dog found on the street starved and on
the brink of death until a rescue group
stepped in to help as the dog continues
to fight for its life at the hospital
there's a reward for anyone who can help
bring her abusers forward Victoria saw
how has the story from the veterinarian
emergency and Critical Care Center we do
want to warn you some of the images may
be disturbing
seven-year-old Althea is supposed to be
doing what dogs do best running around
and looking for snacks she's looking
better today but instead this pup
doesn't know when she'll be leaving the
hospital she doesn't have a fever
anymore for this to happen it was
Unthinkable Tina Hayes were the biggest
pet rescue project has been with Althea
every day at the hospital ever since she
was brought in these are her ribs guys
earlier this month Althea was found on
the street and was first taken to the
animal foundation where employees
reached out to the rescue group for help
they know that we are not afraid of
those critical cases she's just Skin and
Bones she was only at like 23 24 pounds
chances of Althea surviving were slim
videos showing Althea too weak needing
to be carried into the car she's just
almost given up at that time her frail
body and rough pause giving us a glimpse
of what she went through it's been a
torture for her scrounging for food
trying to figure out what's going to be
her next meal although we don't know
what althea's prognosis will be she's
proven she's a fighter even by her
lifting her head up like this just a
little bit on her own it's a big step
towards her recovery she's
showing signs of hey I want to get out
of here a huge difference from just
Tuesday where althea's face was swelling
up and she needed a feeding tube but
things can change every minute in the
emergency room for now while Althea will
continue to fight this fight with the
help of a few small meals a day and some
tender loving care say bye Victoria Saha
eight news now
oh as we mentioned there is a reward for
anyone who has information to help catch
althea's abusers we do have information
on our website where to submit your tips
and if you'd like to donate toward her
medical expenses we will have that up on
our site as well